[Music]
all right you're taking a live look now
at tropicana on the overpass on i-15 now
ndot is about to begin a massive
multi-phase project to revamp this area
over the stretch of three years now it's
a 24 7 move that will also impact dean
martin drive as well as a portion of
frank sinatra now while the payoff of
course will be worth it in the end in
the beginning it's raising concern for
some business owners in the area they
hope this project won't keep customers
away
just like with everything everybody you
know you adjust lisa gay has been an
ambassador for the liberace garage for
years she enjoys spreading the word of
the late singer and his legacy but hopes
the upcoming 300 million dollar ndot
project won't keep them in the shadows
it's going to impact everybody going
through here but it's also going to
highlight
what goes on in this business park along
with the other businesses that are up
and
located here right on d martin justin
hopkins with the nevada department of
transportation says the three-year
project is scheduled to begin late
summer and will be divided into four
sections this project has been in the
works for about seven years
we've been planning it long before there
was an allegiance stadium or a t-mobile
arena and
it's really going to improve safety and
mobility
in the tropicana i-15 interchange work
for phase one hopkins says will include
raising and widening the bridge adding a
fourth lane sidewalk expansion and the
removal of a signal light we're also
changing the traffic flow of dean martin
so
instead of having to come up and stop at
tropicana it's going to continue under
tropicana so drivers aren't going to
have to stop there the project will
impact areas at different times hopkins
says notices will alert drivers of
detours to minimize confusion and keep
businesses like this one in the clear
for daily operations because it is a
part of the hollywood cause museum
there's a flow and then they find out oh
my goodness gracious this is the
liberace side
well governor steve salak and ndoth are
expected to have more information about
this project tomorrow as construction
will be ongoing during two major events
here in las vegas and of course we're
talking about the super bowl and formula
one